we're going to start today in australia
where progressives scored a massive
victory in the australian elections
those were on saturday dozens of you
emailing me about this and saying david
you've got to cover what's happening in
australia because not only is it a
massive victory for the left it's also a
big signal about what could be possible
maybe
in the united states if the united
states became significantly less crazy
and we'll get to that in a moment
the liberal party in australia led by
the prime minister scott morrison wanted
a fourth term in a row
and the opposition the main opposition
the strongest opposition was the
left-wing labour party led by anthony
albanese
votes are still being counted but it
does appear as of this morning as though
the labor party will have the ability to
form a government due to some major wins
that they had and as of right now and
again they're still counting votes these
numbers may change as of this morning i
should say
this morning australia time
labor looks to be up to 73 seats
while the liberal party appears to have
lost 24 seats from 75 before the
election
down to only 51. this is a big
defeat for the centrist liberal party
and it is a crushing victory
for the left wing labour party now also
of note the green party led by adam bant
appears to have secured three seats they
previously had one so gaining two from
one to three seats as of this morning
the green party although the final
numbers may change a little bit so this
would make anthony albanese the fourth
labor leader
and by the way i hope i'm pronouncing
that correctly the fourth labor leader
to win control of the government since
world war ii
so the first question is how on earth
did labor achieve this what did they run
on well a huge component of labor's 2022
platform
was climate change
it was a platform of
renewal not revolution
and labor making a number of promises
along the lines of the environment and
dealing with climate change labor
promised to nearly double australia's
2030 target cuts to carbon emissions
saying let's cut by 43 percent by 2030
and be it completely net zero by 2050
very ambitious is it possible to do that
well time will tell but they ran on it
and the voters liked it
transitioning to renewable energy
upgrade the nation's energy grid
roll out solar banks and community
batteries as many as many of you know
it's great that solar panels are
becoming more and more efficient but
you've got to be able to store that
energy to really increase the viability
of solar
at a larger level um the labour party
said that they would approve new coal
mines
if they stack up environmentally and
economically so not saying we're not
doing any more fossil fuels but saying
it's it's really got to make sense in
context a promise to keep the uh
australian great barrier reef more
protected to protect endangered species
to do more about bush fire recovery and
also campaigned on increasing
australia's federal national minimum
wage more funding for child care centers
nursing homes and disability services
and understand that this is not
communism
this is not socialism there were right
wingers all over twitter and all over
truth central and all of these other
places saying australia has gone
completely communist now the really
funny thing is
the various many of the very same people
would say that the liberal party was
also communist now understand the the
this is true
what i would call left center left
you've got the center
you've got the center left which would
be like the liberal party like justin
trudeau in canada more or less that's
center left and then you've got this is
not far left this is what i would call
left center left it's social democracy
it's certainly to the left of biden and
justin trudeau but it is not socialism
and it is not communism it's basically
where i am it's social democracy in
something more or less approximating the
nordic model the northern european model
so
understand that many of the same people
that are now saying oh australia has
elected socialists
they say justin trudeau is a socialist
they said that the australian liberal
party liberal party was also socialist
when they were not so these people you
can't really go to them this is going to
be a major experiment can labor
in power get things done
and maybe even more importantly are the
things labor wants to do
actually viable will they work because
another big
criticism of many of the ideas that i
and other social democrats espouse is
that stuff would never work if you had
the opportunity to make it law to make
it policy to actually do this stuff it
will implode your country it will be a
disaster for your country well let's see
and depending on the level of
obstruction that's possible in australia
we may in a few years have some answers
do these ideas actually work
despite what the right loves to say when
people like me and others propose them
in the united states so it's going to be
a fascinating time and this is
we can't shortchange what this is this
is a massive victory
for the left
running on climate change
environmental justice economic justice
renewable energy all of these things
we've been talking about a couple of
notes stephanie from australia wrote in
to me and said quote
one of the most interesting aspects of
this has been a large number of very
wealthy traditionally liberal party
inner city districts being taken by a
group of loosely aligned independents
who are economically moderate right but
pro action on climate change political
integrity and gender equality this is
being seen as a repudiation of the
conservative government's move to the
right towards a more republican style
would an independent movement like that
with funding from rich moderate
conservative backers as the case here
have any chance in similar areas of the
u.s well the question in the u.s is
i don't know that we have that group
i mean
i guess anecdotally there are some
center-right moderates who are quite
socially liberal and pro-action on
climate change
but i don't really know that that's
really a big contingent i mean here you
know if you if you think of the center
right in the united states and i know
everybody this is fraught because people
would say those aren't really
center-right people if you think of the
center right in the united states which
is people like joe manchin and mitt
romney
they don't seem big
on taking bold action on climate
uh they seem to really want to kind of
just protect business interests when it
comes to thinking about climate so sure
stephanie it would work if we had that
contingent in the united states i don't
know that we do but i'm willing to have
my mind changed also our friend josh
zepps
who i've been on his show i don't
remember if he's been on my show he's
australian he had a good tweet quote the
lesson of the australian election is
unambiguous if you refuse to address a
big problem that voters persistently say
they care about they'll smack you down
australians are fed up with excuses
about climate chaos they've been saying
this for years welcome to democracy
hopeful results
in australia a really big deal
as many of you know i'm a busy person i
don't always have the exact correct
nutritional plan for my meals every
single day and that's why i also take a
multivitamin and a couple of supplements
but doing them all separately can be a
little bit time-consuming which is why
athletic greens is just fantastic and
they're one of our sponsors i've been
using the athletic greens since last
year it just really simplifies nutrition
i just do a scoop of the ag-1 and i'm
getting 75 high-quality vitamins and
minerals and my probiotics and it's all
from whole food sources i drink it in
the morning i know i'm good i don't have
to be messing around with different
pills and supplements or whatever or
spend time planning when what time of
day do i need to take each one i just
get it all with one scoop you can put it
in a smoothie you can drink it straight
it tastes great and then i'm just good
for the day
it supports gut health and i'm getting
everything that i need and i'm looking
for athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one-year supply of
vitamin d plus five free travel packs
when you go to athleticgreens.com
pacman and the link is down below